إن حماية المكان الذي نعيش فيه ونعيش
حياة صحية أمر مهم ويسير جنبًا
إلى جنب مع العديد من الإجراءات التي
يمكننا اتخاذها كأفراد لتقليل
انبعاثات الكربون لدينا أيضًا
فوائد صحية إيجابية الدكتورة أليسا جوردون هي
المديرة الطبية للاستدامة في
كليفلاند كلينك.  إن تناول
نظام غذائي نباتي مع التركيز على
الأطعمة مثل الفواكه والخضروات والمكسرات
والبذور وعدد أقل من المنتجات الحيوانية
ليس مفيدًا لجسمك فحسب ، بل يمكن أن يساعد أيضًا في
تقليل انبعاثات الكربون الخاصة بك ، كما
يقول بوردن إنه يجب أيضًا التفكير في الذهاب إلى
سوق المزارعين المحليين هذا  يساعد في تحسين
البصمة الكربونية عن طريق تقليل
البصمة الكربونية للنقل
للطعام ويحافظ أيضًا على العناصر الغذائية في
الطعام نظرًا لأنه طازج ويدعم
الشركات المحلية مع ارتفاع درجة حرارة الطقس ،
يقول جوردون إنه يجب عليك المشي أو
ركوب الدراجات إلى حيث تحتاج إلى الذهاب لإبقائك
نشيطًا و  إن تقليل الملوثات
في الهواء يتمتع أيضًا بحراسة الطبيعة
ليس فقط له فوائد في
الخروج من المنزل والتحرك ، ولكن يمكن
أيضًا أن يساعد صحتك فقط في
خفض ضغط الدم ويعزز
جهاز المناعة لديك ، كما أنه يجعل الأطفال
أكثر استرخاءً واهتمامًا مما
يحسن التعلم  وأداء المدرسة
أخيرًا أطفئ مصابيح التليفزيون
وغيرها من الأجهزة الإلكترونية عندما لا تكون قيد الاستخدام ،
يمكن أن يساعد ذلك في تعزيز النوم بشكل أفضل ويقلل من
استخدام الطاقة في المنزل وفي العمل
من أجل الصحة الدقيقة أنا آندي جاثر